[Applause]
please welcome joanna garcia swisher
hi tiana how are you
it's so fun to be on your show because i
watch it all the time
you do of course i do i follow
everything you do
well thank you for doing this with us
and you're in your sweet magnolia's
kitchen
right now and you're filming season two
yes we're here in georgia i was like so
excited that we were filming on the
stages today because these are some of
my favorite
sets and even this looks like it looks
like a super fancy top-notch kitchen but
there's
barely any electricity in it but we're
gonna get through this together
i have to say it does look really chic
and
very professional and i really am
excited to talk to you about your
website too
the happy place i mean the name is so
good by the way how is that name not
taken
i don't know and i actually thought it
was so when i was kind of creating it i
was like oh
you know it's it's going to be called
something like the happy place they're
like well why not that i'm like i can do
that
so yeah so it's been um a lifesaver for
me in so many ways but to focus on
the positive and the joy even in the
midst of
you know things that are difficult in
life which is kind of inevitable about
life it's the beauty
of the journey um it's been a real
blessing to be able to carve out
the slivers of light and um and all of
it and sometimes they're larger slivers
huge rays of sunshine and sometimes you
have to really search for them but
to have an opportunity to have a
destination it's such a beautiful
supportive place it's just been
a great blessing and now we all get to
be in the happy place with you and
you're gonna actually teach us
a great springtime recipe from that
gorgeous kitchen that's
in the happy place right you can find it
there
yes i will be able to i'm going to share
all of these recipes with you i'm always
tinkering in the kitchen i'm not
complete aficionado but i do what i can
on the happy place we always say it
doesn't have to be pinterest perfect you
just have to kind of put your heart into
it oh
i love that joanna it doesn't have to be
pinterest perfect okay
i don't know if you've ever seen me in a
kitchen it is
definitely not pinterest perfect so
teach me i
am your student what are we making okay
we are making a fresh jalapeno corn
pickled salsa so um i'm gonna get right
to it and kind of show you how i do it
because this is so easy and you can
really make it your own
so you start by taking um a few cups of
fresh foil corn
and then put it in an ice bath um
it kind of keeps the color all nice and
bright and we like it to look pretty in
our jar right
yes and then i have thinly sliced
red onion which is kind of like my one
of my favorite things
on in life and then we go for one of the
other stars of our show
the fresh jalapeno and then
lime juice who doesn't love lime juice
and in the spring i'm just craving
everything fresh and with a lot of
vibrancy and this kind of just
gives it that extra little kick now we
have a little fresh cilantro
then we're going to go with a little bit
of red pepper flakes because
why not right let's kick it up a notch
so we'll mix it up now
while i'm doing all of this mixture i'm
boiling my vinegar
water sugar and salt mixture
that's over here and that is the
pickling juice
this is the pickling juice this is the
big daddy
yum yum big daddy yum yum
i just want to say joanna hashtag big
daddy yum yum which
might sound different in that context
but
this catches on i'm fully crediting you
with that but like i'm really into it
it's all you joanna
read it um okay so now
then you stick all of this in your handy
dandy jar
now magic of television which i've
always wanted to say this because i'm
not a chef but i always love how they
have the finished product
um i put it in little jars these jars
don't last long in my house because i
will put this on
everything and then once i put this
mixture in
i let it cool and leave it on the
counter top and once it's cool i'll seal
it up and i'll put it in the fridge and
it'll last
about a week if it lasts that long um
okay so
another thing that i've been doing so
much of is i'm always craving
you know fresh easy meals on the go and
so i'm not a huge meal prep
girl or a leftover girl but i do like
cutting up fresh veggies in the house
and having it there easy for the girls
to grab and go
and really honestly easy to make these
salads so i kind of put you could put
a lettuce of any your liking um i
put a little quinoa i have a little
brown rice quinoa mixture here
so i like something a little to stick to
my ribs because i'm probably about eight
hours more of work after this
um i do fresh cucumber
a little bit of boiled egg matchstick
carrots chickpeas and you've got this
nice fresh salad
and then here comes
my fresh pickled
jalapeno corn and i'm trying to make it
look really really pretty for you
i noticed joanna that you put croutons
and i'm salivating because i love
croutons so much drew i'm not a fancy
bird you know me
but i've been making my fresh my own
croutons which i just feel really fancy
about this
and i've been doing it in the most epic
air fryer
airfryer from walmart and honestly i i
promise you
everyone at home um she did not tell me
to do that i actually bought that i
can't believe i got to atlanta without
my air fryer so i immediately went out
and bought it i love all of your stuff
it's so
beautiful and chic and gorgeous and
honestly this thing is
incredible i did chicken in it last
night for the girls
but here are my fresh croutons and
they're so easy that
we eat
[Music]
i love it by the way this is so
beautiful
and i'm so glad that you're bringing
this wonderful
show into the world people need shows
like this you know they make us
feel good and i love the messaging
and i'm so happy for your season two
congratulations
may you have a healthy happy success
making it there
in your gorgeous kitchen and be sure to
check out joanna's website
the happy place for even more amazing
recipes and content
joanna thank you for coming on the show
[Applause]
[Music]